Joe Biden is wrapping up his Whirlwind
tour of Vietnam as he wraps up most
engagements these days by muttering
listlessly before shuffling off the
stage and uh I's
see I'm just follow my orders
here so what
we got the
cards staff is anybody having
spoken I ain't calling on you I'm
calling say there five
questions Anita
VA oh yeah Anita V VOA he opens up he
says Hey where's the staff where was I
supposed who was I supposed to call on I
can't find who I was supposed to call on
all right does anyone have questions and
then some of the actual reporters who
might ask potentially a challenging
question raise their hands he says no no
not you I'm not calling on you who was
who was I supposed to call on it anyway
all right bye the worst part of Biden's
performance is not the
senility which we've all known about for
years and it's not even the cynicism
which we've all known about for
decades it's the
transparency Biden isn't even trying to
hide his
unaccountability he isn't even trying to
pretend to take serious questions from
an independent press he isn't even
really claiming to be running the
show in some ways transparency is worse
than deceit at least if Biden were
trying to deceive us into thinking that
he's really in charge and responsive to
the people at least it would signal that
he respects our intelligence or that he
cares what we think but he doesn't he
jokes about his
irresponsibility he doesn't campaign he
doesn't act as though he needs our votes
and maybe that's because with all the
recent changes to our electoral system
he doesn't I'm Michael nolles this is
the Michael nlls
[Music]
show we've got really important news
Miley Cyrus is opening up about her
divorce but we're we're going to push
that pressing national news just a
little bit to get to more of uh Biden
because yesterday was obviously the
anniversary of the September 11th Terror
attacks very traumatic day
for everybody my age and older and a a
day of you know incredible historical
significance for people who were younger
than me who don't really remember what
happened and Joe Biden decided to mark
that day also by not remembering what
happened Ground Zero in New York and I
remember standing there the next day and
looking at the building I felt like I
was looking through the gates of hell it
looked so devastating because the way
you could away from where you could
stand that didn't happen on September
12th uh Joe Biden was in Washington DC
and he was Voting in the senate in the
capital on a resolution to condemn the
World Trade Center attack
he probably believes maybe he believes
that he was in New York on that
day I actually think it's it's not that
he knows that he's lying and it's also
not that he is totally bought into the
lie that he actually believes that it's
true I think there's a third possibility
here which is that Joe Biden doesn't
care if what he says is
true that's that's called cynicism
it's between deceit and cility there
there's this place where Joe Biden has
lived for his entire political career
and it's cynicism indifference to the
truth Pontius pilot is probably the
typical cynic who when he's confronted
by
Christ who says I am the truth pilate
says what is truth oh what is truth come
on there's no such thing as truth I
think that's where Joe Biden
is he just doesn't he'll just say
whatever sounds good and maybe he
believes it maybe he doesn't I think he
just doesn't really care and when you're
in a place where the
politicians are often going to mislead
you but when you're in a place where
they don't even care they're not even
conscious of the fact that they're
misleading you for whom words are just
sounds that sometimes make people feel
more inclined to like you and applaud
rather than words constituting
meaningful speech with which we can
deliberate and come to rational
conclusions about the world and and
decide on a program of for the entire
political Community what is good what is
true what is beautiful how are we going
to flourish when we get to a point where
words are just sounds we are reduced to
just grunting baboons we've ceased to
live in human society I don't want to be
too hyperbolic about it but the fact
that that speech has been robbed of its
meaning the fact that we are no longer
even scandalized when our politicians
lie to us or even more scandalous don't
care about the truth at all that
accounts for a great deal of our present
political problems there are always
political problems in every society but
ours right now are different and worse
than they have been in the past now
speaking of presidents in the
presidential race president Trump the
chief rival to Joe Biden right now has
just received a really really big
endorsement this from South Dakota
govern Governor Christine
n it is my honor to present to you the
man in the arena he is a man of
significance he is the leader the
fighter that our country needs he has my
full and complete endorsement for
president of the United States of
America I will do everything I can to
help him win and save this country
ladies and gentlemen the 45th and the
47th president of the United States it's
Donald J Trump there you have it I
generally have not covered
endorsements I mentioned early on when
DeSantis was getting some some
congressmen because they were some of
the first endorsements that he had
gotten people who decided to turn on
Trump and go for another guy I haven't
really covered many of the endorsements
since then the reason I'm covering this
one the reason that this one is
significant is
because christye Nome is not just a
republican Governor she was a potential
presidential candidate Christine gnome
like Glenn yunan in Virginia was
obviously considering running for
president herself she set herself up to
do that during coid she was playing kind
of koi with it after coid right up until
a couple days ago I guess now she's
decided that she's going to endorse
Trump which to me says not only that she
thinks that Trump is the best candidate
which is explicitly what she's saying
but what it what it means is she
believes that Trump just is going to be
the nominee and so she thinks not only
is it her interest to get on Trump's
side in this battle between him and
DeSantis and B and Chris Christie or
whoever but she thinks it's in her
interest not to run against him trust me
if christye Nome thought that Donald
Trump had any weakness right now and
that she would have a shot at the
presidency she would be running inside
every Governor is a president just
waiting to get out some uncharitable
people have asked how many Governors how
many presidents are waiting inside of
Chris Christie which I don't that's not
very nice that's not that's not a nice
thing to say at all but Christy Nome
wants to be president and she's not
going to run and she is going to endorse
this guy because she thinks in another
sign of something we've been talking
about for weeks that the presidential
primary is if not over pretty severely
tilted in the direction of Donald John
Trump okay this is a man who likes to
have his name written in gold all over
the United States all over the world and
when you want gold you got to check out
Birch gold right now text Noles to 98
9898 Vladimir Putin called the US
Dollars drop in dominance quote
objective and irreversible as Brazil
Russia India China and South Africa
formally agreed to use local currencies
in trade instead of the US dollar as
demand for the dollar weakens the buying
power of the dollar weakens that is why
Birch gold is busier than ever investors
and Savers are looking to harness the
power of physical gold held in a tax
sheltered Ira you can too you can
protect your IRA or for 1K by
diversifying with gold from Birch gold
as the US dollar continues to receive
pressure from foreign countries digital
currency and central banks arm yourself
with information on how to protect your
savings learn if gold is right for you
too text nolles kwes to 998 9898 they
will send you a free info kit on gold
with an A+ rating with the Better
Business Bureau thousands of happy
customers and countless five-star
reviews I trust Birch gold to help you
diversify into gold if Central Bank
digital currency becomes a reality it
will be nice to have some gold to depend
on right now Tex nolles canes to 98
9898 speaking of presidential candidates
the V ramaswami has just come out
another step in his bold campaign to not
play it safe to keep shaking things up
to take to take strong stances on policy
issues the vake has just come out
against Birthright
citizenship so I would end Birthright
citizenship for illegal immigrants IMM
and the children of illegal well what
does it mean for everybody else I mean
we're all citizens whether sixth
generation or first generation in my
case if you're born in this country you
have citizens trip if you're born under
legal circumstances but I think that if
somebody comes to this country illegally
and has a child while here I do think we
have to end Birthright citizenship but
does that mean you'd Deport like a
one-year-old I think you would you would
do the family you would take the whole
family unit so so I'm strongly opposed
to policies that would separate kids
from their parents I think that that was
discussed even in in the Trump
Administration and otherwise as a tactic
for deterring people from coming as a
Pro-Am leader I will not adopt such a
policy but we will send back the family
unit as such and I think that if you
came to this country illegally the right
answer is you have to be sent back to
your country of origin come back through
the same legal means getting in the same
line that everybody who's coming into
this country leg Al is already
pursuing I tend to agree I think he
makes a good point here and you're going
to have some people mostly on the left
but even some people on the right who
say how dare you Birthright citizenship
is a core Bedrock principle of this
country you're upending well it's not
actually it's not a lot of what a lot of
people believe about the Constitution
and American history and the American
form of government is not true a lot of
it
revisionism from the middle of the 20th
century and this would be a good example
of that I'm not saying that it's clear
from the text of the Constitution that
the children born to illegal immigrants
on us soil are not citizens that's not
what I'm saying what I'm saying is I
think it's pretty clearly an open legal
question here's the text the text that
we have is from the 14th Amendment is
all persons born or naturalized in the
United States and subject to the
jurisdiction thereof are citizens of the
United States and of the state wherein
they
reside now the the key here is subject
to the jurisdiction thereof obviously
anybody who is on American soil ever is
subject to the jurisdiction of the US in
a certain sense in that when you travel
to foreign places you have to observe
the laws of those places but they are
not subject to the jurisdiction in the
the full sense in that they are not
citizens of that country there are clear
exceptions to this uh issue made by
determined by the courts over time uh
Native Americans were not subject uh
children of diplomats not subject uh
occupying soldiers not subject to the
jurisdiction thereof and there therefore
all of their children did not
automatically receive Birthright
citizenship but it's been debated for a
very long time now the case that that
most clearly weighed in on this was uh
from 1898 it was us versus Wong Kim Arc
which uh seemed to determine the matter
on the side of Birthright citizenship
but it remains an open question and it
gets to something we were talking about
yesterday which is we look to statutes
we look to constitutional interpretation
we look even back before the founding of
our country we look to the common law
tradition which is another place where
we get some evidence for Birthright
citizenship though it's a little bit
different when we're talking about
whether or not someone is Born the
subject to a King which is what we get
from the English common law tradition
versus a citizen of a republic such as
the United States which
entails one might argue many more
Privileges and many fewer
responsibilities uh it's an open
question and the answers are not always
clear and changing political
circumstances sometimes change the way
that Eternal principles can be applied
in politics that's why politics is
different from uh archaeology that's why
politics is different from history
that's why politics is different
different from philosophy because there
are changing circumstances in the
present that we are in so not only are
we interpreting documents but we are
writing the script as well and it is
simply a fact that 7 a half% of all
births in the United States we're
talking about
300,000 births per year are to illegal
aliens 7 and a
half% that's in addition to the millions
of foreigners just entering our country
illegally and changing our political
structure then their children who
account for 7 and a half% of all us
births per year all of that population
growth 75% are going to be US citizens
that is a radical changing of the
demographics of the United States and a
radical changing of the citizenship
which is a radical changing of the
political order that's why the Democrats
are encouraging it and I know I got in
trouble a little bit for pointing out
that sometimes we need to be a little uh
more willing to wield power in the cases
of emergencies that that threaten the
entire entirety of the law not just one
minor aspect of the law but the entirety
of the law the entirety of the political
Community this might be a good example
of that where if if you have contrary to
the letter of the law and certainly to
the spirit of the law where you have uh
a a foreign Invasion radically changing
your political Community which in a
republic by the way means you're
changing the whole thing because we're
supposed to have self-government here
well in that case we might need to
clarify what exactly is meant by by all
persons born or naturalized in the
United States or citizens of the United
States because we know the 14th
amendment was passed over the question
of slavery that's what it was about the
14th amendment has absolutely nothing to
do with Guatemalan economic migrants
pouring across the border the border
which will not be defended by democrats
because they know that it will give them
political advantage and which won't be
defended even by the Chamber of Commerce
Republicans because they want to get
Chief
labor we know that okay so maybe we need
to be willing to wield power or we can
just sit on our hands and we can whine
and complain and we can say oh if only
the Democrats would support the Border I
mean we're not going to do anything
about it because you know us versus Wong
Kim Arc in 1898 said that we can't so
we're just G to we're just going to sit
there it's the same thing as the people
who say well we can't we can't regulate
Google because you see if we Google is
controlling the entire Public Square and
all of our speech in the society but you
know look if we regulate Google that's a
private business they can do whatever
they want well then maybe the Liberals
will regulate our
businesses which they're already doing
well if we impose certain boundaries on
and manage the way that speech is
governed in our society well the left
might do that too which they're
obviously already doing that's the whole
point that's the problem we have to
address
okay and that's a big that's a big issue
because if you sit on your hands long
enough 7 and a half% of all births per
year you just have a new country at a
certain point and V sees that and V is
this is why he's a candidate who is
largely favored by by
younger conservatives who recognize that
Ronald Reagan's a great guy Bill
Buckley's a great guy we love our we
love our 20th century conservatives but
we have new challenges now they dealt
with their challenges we have new
challenges now and we need to handle
them ourselves now speaking of people in
places that they don't
belong there's a
[Music]
fella but time
very very important for all of you for
women and and especially for men is your
hair
thinning well you got to check out
provia right now go to provia.com are
you one of the millions of American men
and women dealing with premature hair
thinning and hair loss well maybe you're
scared about inheriting that thinning
look because it runs in the family
finally there is a real solution that
delivers on its promise without the
harsh side effects unwanted chemicals
and unpleasant smells provia Hair Care
uses a safe natural ingredient called
procapil to effectively Target the three
main causes of premature hair thinning
and loss Pia aborts healthy scalp
circulation and delivers nourishing
nutrients strengthen hair follicles and
anchor them to your scalp provia
guarantees more hair on your head than
in the shower drain provia is effective
for men and women of any age and safe
uncolored treated and styled hair provia
Works guaranteed or 100% of your money
back it is that easy you know I have
relied on my hair a lot in my public
life right now new customers save over
50% off pria's introductory package at
Pria hair.com see results for yourself
right now do not wait provia
hair.com if you're even
mildly familiar with this show you're
probably aware of my autumnal affinity
for a certain seasonal beverage
I am a certified ficado of the PSL the
pumpkin spice latte I am a swarey
Italian man for nine months of the year
but then when fall rolls around I
transform I transition into a very pale
basic white girl in a North Face jacket
and an infinity scarf so what better way
to bring the fall atmosphere into your
home than with the allnew Michael N
pumpkin spice candle that's right baby
it's wonderful it's filled with h it's
filled with cinnamon and presumably
pumpkin spice it's now available in my
collection at dailywire.com
shop these are going to sell out fast
I'm sure I know that they are uh they're
probably sold out already by the time
you're listening to if you do want one
go go get it right now uh and then uh
also speaking of my collection yes or no
the game has sold out again uh so I
warrant you don't say I didn't tell you
so all right I always tell you this and
it it did sell out so I hate to say it
but that's the way it goes uh it will
come back in stock you need to secure
your game if you have not already
especially as we start to approach
Thanksgiving and the Christmas season
they're going to sell even faster if you
already have the game be sure to get the
all new conspiracy theory expansion pack
in time for spooky season do not wait
order your pumpkin spice candles and
your yes or no game over at
dailywire.com shop
today speaking of been alone so long but
this
[Music]
time that's not authoritarian that's
just that's liberal in the truest sense
of the word that's good that's right
that's the point of being a citizen and
a self-governing republic come on ah all
right that rant is over but we're still
speaking of women's issues and we get to
Miley Cyrus you know I'm a Miley fan I
mean I don't listen to her music I don't
really listen to any modern music but I
kind of get a kick out of her because
she says things that are at least
contrary to what the Liberals always
believe sometimes and I think she's got
a good voice and I always loved Party in
the USA so here is Miley Cyrus
explaining her
divorce I have to slow down cuz this is
like actually serious so glassenberry
was in June which was when the decision
had been made that me and Liam's
commitment to being married just really
came from of course a place of Love
first cuz we've been together for 10
years but also from a place of trauma
and just trying to rebuild as quickly as
we could the day of the show was the day
that I had decided that it was no longer
going to work in my life to be in that
in that relationship so that was another
moment where the work the performance
the character came first and I guess
that's why it's now so important to me
for that to not be the case that the
human comes first notice how clinical
and controlled Miley is here if you're
listening to this and I bring up this
story not because I care about celebrity
gossip with Miley Cyrus but because it
it tells you a lot about how to engage
in society and a lot about how our
political order
Works Miley is reading off an iPad she's
she's got her words written out
perfectly here and she's being very
controlled she goes and I and that was
the moment at which I decided that this
relationship was not going to work in my
life and it's all this really vague
clinical language but then she say she
goes look I've always just worked okay
and the show must go on and I was
working and I was working too much and I
I think she's implying here the reason
her marriage fell apart was because she
and her husband just were too focused on
their careers and just always put their
work which is show business
first above everything else and I think
that's what a lot of people
do a lot of people put their jobs first
that's a cause of a lot of marital
strain a lot of people put their careers
first and their education and they're
settling in to their professional life
first that's why they don't get married
until sometimes it's too late or it's
much more difficult to get married this
is why they don't have kids they put off
having kids until very often it's too
late and it's a it's a lie it's it's a
scam and they come to regret it and the
people who get suckered in by even
something that seems Noble you know
getting on your hustle and working hard
and putting the show first even they
will come to regret that very often
because you want to work hard and you
want to be serious in your professional
life and you want to have good material
means but that's not
everything okay you want to put on a
good show everybody's performing these
days not only are we at the point of
society where everyone's going to be
famous for 15 minutes everyone is famous
at least at a local level whenever they
want to be because we're always all per
performing for Tik Tok and Instagram and
Snapchat and Facebook and whatever
Twitter so we're all always performing
sometimes we put that show first and
this reminds me of a line that a a Dante
professor of mine told me once in Italy
you know I was brief in my wayward youth
I was briefly a professional actor and
this Dante professor of mine he said you
know yes migut I uh I wanted to be an
actor as a young boy I took it s very
seriously my mother discouraged it she
told me there's the door you want to be
an actor there's the door but I thought
about it and I I felt so sorry for him
and I said oh no Professor you you never
got to be an actor you never got to live
out your dream when he said uh
Mutu I used to want to be an actor but
now I am the real
thing and I love that line I use that
line yeah yeah I used to be an actor now
I'm the real thing and it's better to be
the real thing it's very nice to play a
married woman on a sitcom or in a movie
I'm sure Miley Cyrus enjoys doing that
it is better to actually be a wife and a
mother it's better to be the real thing
it's true for men too I'm sure it's fun
being a rock I've never been a rock star
but I'm sure it's fun to be a rock star
and to play this this kind of character
where you're just beloved by everybody
it's better to be beloved by your family
who
actually will continue to care for you
once the music dies down where that
where that where that's a deeper kind of
love and commitment and reality it's
better to be the real thing Megan Markle
gave up being an actual princess so that
she could audition to try to play
princesses in Hollywood that's how
backwards our society we love the
semblance of the thing but we're so
afraid of the reality of it because
we're afraid of commitment because we're
afraid of commitment not just to another
person not just to uh circumstances in a
home and a place but a commitment even
to an idea even to the
truth so we go out and we perform even
modern Spirit spirituality you know we
make these vague gestures about the
universe man you know and like the
spirits and The Vibes and but we don't
actually commit to religious belief
because that would then impose certain
obligations on
us because if you really think that you
know your prayers do something then that
raises the question well how do they do
something who hears our prayers who
answers our prayers what does what does
he God demand of us as a result uh of of
that line of thinking theology which is
faith- seeking understanding we don't
want any of that so we just keep making
these half-hearted gestures we just keep
playing roles in movies in on Tik Tok in
our daily lives and that will leave us
empty the show is good but the real
thing is a lot better now speaking of
The Show Must Go On got some good news a
few days ago finally getting to it now
you remember in the spring I I gave a
talk at the University of Pittsburgh and
this was protested it was it was the
last in a series of talks one was with
my colleague kavat Phillips one was with
Riley Gaines my fellow Tennessean and
then the final one was me and the the
left in Pittsburgh and and Pennsylvania
was very upset that I was speaking
because at pack I uh made a comment that
was obviously true and uh which the libs
were Furious about but it's a comment
that I'm not allowed to say on YouTube I
think you know which one I'm talking
about you know about eradication from
public life entirely and uh so there
were something like 11,000 signatures
against my coming the university tried
to shut it down the local politicians
tried to shut it down antifa terrorists
tried to shut it down by throwing an
explosive at the building while we were
walking on stage still though we were
able to go on they kept threatening they
set the street on fire they were ring in
at the very end of our of our debate the
cops basically rushed us off stage and
and out of the building um so we had to
cancel the meet and greet had to cancel
some of the events we had afterward and
then the University of Pittsburgh tried
to punish the college Republicans for
having the audacity to host Me by
charging them an $118,000 almost
$119,000 security fee and uh isi the
group that brought me the inter
Collegiate Studies Institute and the
college Republicans they they fought
back really hard and pit got a lot of
bad press and now they are no longer
requiring the CRS to pay that fee that
fee was
effectively a conservatives on campus
fee that was the fee to say hey we're a
public university and we're not allowed
to stop you from bringing ordinary
conservatives to campus but we're going
to we're going to punish you for it
we're going to bankrupt you if you ever
actually do it and so it was very
important that pit backed down and those
jerks over at pit finally called Uncle
and that's great news and it's great
news especially because my new speech
season is approaching we're launching it
this month I'll give you the full rund
down of schools in a few weeks we got
some great schools this semester we're
going to launch it September 26th at
Georgetown so if you're in Washington DC
head on over I think you can reserve
tickets now uh so go go check it out
I'll see you in DC and please don't
throw any explosives at me and if you do
I hope Georgetown doesn't try to charge
us all like 20 grand just for uh just
for having ducked and missed the
explosive as you
know spooky season is quickly
approaching there will be demon out on
the prow and I'm not just talking about
those woke corporations who look upon
your values with disdain let's unwoke
Halloween with Jeremy's chocolate our
delicious chocolates come in two forms
he him with
nuts and she her which are nutless just
as God intended don't be a ghoul head on
over to Jeremy chocolate.com in order
your uh chocolates right now in time for
Halloween my favorite comment yesterday
is from a Romano 703 who says say this
guy is always teaching me new words
perspicacious wow yes I love that word
perspicacious having having ready
insight into things perspicacity is that
a good one I like that bill Buckley used
to do that Bill O'Reilly used to do that
too he just have a word out there they
sprinkle in perspicacious H it's a good
one which one should I do today I don't
know I haven't even thought of it
speaking of
schools great news out of New York New
York City teachers
who refused to get the fouchy ouchi are
now going to get their jobs back with
back pay this is according to New York
state supreme court judge Ralph portio
who ruled that the decision to fire 10
employees of the New York education
department and deny them religious
exemptions was unlawful arbitrary and
capricious so that's good news we're so
glad to hear it but unfortunately this
is still a win for the libs because the
libs
by passing these mandates which were
obviously illegal and unconstitutional
and which over time when if people just
stood firm very likely would have been
ruled that way as we're seeing around
the country and and even in New York
they still used the mandates to pressure
everyone else voluntarily to get the
Jabs this was the secret story of the
mandates the mandates were were not
primarily about getting everyone to take
the fouchy ouchi through coercion the
mandates were about getting
enough people voluntarily to take the
fouchy ouchi that even if this thing
were overruled later on it wouldn't
matter they would have already gotten
what they wanted what the libs were
doing here was asking forgiveness rather
than permission which is generally A
good rule in politics politics
especially Republican politics lowercase
R you know Democratic politics lowercase
D is about action it's about things
happening very quickly sometimes the
action happens first the deliberation
happens later well that's what we're
seeing here and they're going to do it
again they're going to try to do the
exact same thing again I hope people
stand up you know daily wire stood up we
took the Biden Administration all the
way to the Supreme Court and we
won but it's happening it's happening
all around the country now speaking of
this issue of immigration and the
emergency and the crisis with
immigration you know that New York city
mayor Eric Adams who's a liberal
Democrat he just came out he said this
immigration crisis this is going to
destroy New York City and this is after
Eric Adams had said for a long time
we're Sanctuary City diversity is our
strength everyone's welcome here but
then they started coming after Greg
Abbott and Ronda santis sent buses up to
New York and all of a sudden Eric Adams
changed his tune well now that Eric
Adams changed his tune even the Liberals
on The View who are as establishment lib
as they get even they after years of
diversities our strength and no one is
illegal and Sanctuary cities are great
they're changing their tune
too this
issue will destroy New York City the
city we
knew we're about to lose but frankly you
know I think we need to find and and
we've dealt with this before I I lived
in uh in Miami I was a migrant an
immigrant in Miami in the 80s you'll
remember when we had the Marielle Boat
Lift 125,000 Cubans came in a matter of
six months it puts tremendous stress on
on on a city on a community on the
social services they need to be
resettled elsewhere they spread out
we're this a massive country and it's
only going to get worse with global
warming and climate change cuz people
can't live in certain parts of this
world and don't forget about this
totally unrelated Boogeyman we got to
get that in here to every story but but
listen to what Anar Anar is a huge Li
but she goes look but they got it we got
to spread these immigrants out we can't
come on he immigrants they're going to
destroy New York City well hold on I
thought the immigrants were our strength
I thought We're a nation of immigrants
New York's a city of the more immigrants
the
better but then Eric Adams mayor of New
York changed his tune and now all the
other Liberals are changing their tune
too why
because Anna Navaro knows that she's on
the same team as Eric
Adams and Eric Adams flipped and so now
the rest of the team is going to
flip this is a concept in political
theory that uh the political boils down
to a distinction between friends and
enemies it's this is uh something that
isn't often spoken about explicitly
because it was articulated most clearly
by a political philosopher named Carl
Schmidt and Karl Schmidt had The
Misfortune of Being a German in the
1930s like haiger and so he's you know
kind of been cancelled but uh even uh
Leo Strauss for instance another great
political
philosopher largely exonerates Carl
Schmidt of all of a lot of the nasty
charges against him and so I think it's
I think it's fair to mention this point
because the point he's making here is
obviously true that the political boils
down to very practical things it's not
just Pie in the Sky guys it's not just
abstractions it boils down to are you on
my team or you on are you on the other
team well if you're on my team I'm going
to show you more grace if you're on the
other team we're going to try to drive
you out of the Public Square and I there
are a lot of squishy Li types who bemoan
the fact that politics has become so
tribal these days politics has always
been tribal poit partisan politics has
always been partisan that's that's what
a party is
and the the this notion that there's a
distinction between friends and enemies
it actually goes much much deeper than
some political differences you know
Democrats and Republicans left and right
it's a it's a basic question you know
Ronald Reagan used to say that we have
we have no no enemies only opponents
here and so he' always talk about his
Democrat opponents and there's something
really beautifully true about that
because if you call your domestic
adversaries your enemies what you're
doing is saying that there is no there's
no cohes political unit here with the
right to declare war with the right to
declare who really is an enemy with the
right to really move the entire body
politic and so I I think it's really
beautiful that Ronald Reagan tried to
avoid that increasingly though you hear
the left talk about us as enemies and
you hear the right talk about the left
as enemies that tell tells you about a
breakdown in the political order there
is a video that I was hoping to get to
today I'll have to just tease you with
this though I don't know how tempting
this is going to be because the video is
absolutely repulsive the mayor of
Burbank California has just subjected
himself to being spanked in public by a
drag
queen I guess we'll get to it tomorrow
not because the video is so
sensationalist but because it tells you
a lot about the Civic religion that is
now governing our society the rest of
the show continues now you know what day
it is
it's Tuesday you don't want to miss it
become a member use code NES canw at
checkout for 2 months free on all annual
[Music]
plans